just of all-christian looking bomb I
mean you've had a little glow up on
reality TV how are you feeling oh it's a
lot but I'm really happy because I get
Demi so are you adjusting to fame is it
weird how is this going for you I've not
really thought of it like that
I'm just kind of riding the wave did you
give her tips would you tell her I just
said you'll be fine so let me ask you a
little bit of backing up about you
coming to paradise and then you sing in
paradise
some people had talked about that the
rules of the show you and I have talked
about that but how did you feel about
staying in paradise any trepidation and
what do you say to people who said she
should have been allowed to stay she's
not of the show well I never really
watched the show so I don't even know
what the rules would be I don't think
there are rules but I just was focused
on my relationship with Emmy and
whatever we wanted to decide as a couple
so and I wanted to explore a
relationship and our love for each other
was that a little crazy for you guys
because you'd kind of been not even
living in the same state and all of a
sudden you're like together on the beach
24/7 what was that like for your
relationship it was crazy
I mean there's definitely ups and downs
that you know you see on the show but
ultimately you go to Paradise to explore
relationships and you focus on them you
don't have distractions so let me talk a
little bit about your kind of issues
with commitments that you are honest
about and how you two worked through
that you were very patient I've just
always not been a fan of committing I
like to do whatever I want to do and I
like to have fun and you know just not
really commit to anything as simple as a
lunch plan with someone but whenever you
need someone who makes you want to
change that I
and that's like Christian did for me it
was really telling and it made me
excited to commit where I was before I
was terrified Christian what was it like
for you to get the call to come on the
show how were you prepped in any way did
you have any idea what was waiting for
you no I had no idea when she left I had
a feeling it was basically over so I
wasn't really sure but my feelings were
so strong when she was gone
so when I got the call I was just
excited to like talk to her I just
wanted to tell her how I all the
realizations of my feelings and how I
fell I wanted to see her and just tell
her you know how I was feeling at that
time how did you two leave it would you
call it a breakup how was it when you
went to go on the show and you know you
didn't have a cellphone to even send a
text or anything you know it wasn't a
breakup there was no conversation that
needed to be had it was just like okay
I'm going nice mm-hmm
it sounds like you'd kept things pretty
light before that very much Christian
for you Derrick's gotten a lot of praise
were you surprised when you heard kind
of what this guy's reaction was or what
was it like for you to watch those
conversations back between the two of
them I just commend him I think he's a
great guy
and we actually became friends after I
got to know him obviously in the
beginning I was just hesitant to get to
know him cuz I of the situation but he
is just everything he's done and just
speaks so highly of his character and I
do wish the best for him and we're all
friends so it's a unique situation but
it's beautiful it's very 2019 you get to
live together now what is that like you
get to be out in public together now
it's just exciting to be normal people
again I just can't wait to do the simple
things together and just not have to
hide so yeah it's been interesting
hiding and it's been a hard definitely
hard fight any like wigs used or what
would have been the tactics for hiding
you know I doesn't even want to take the
risk he's not leaving now okay but also
I don't mind not leaving I like doing
that same-same this is successful
potential here so you crisis laughs turn
into so you guys are now both sporting
rings hold those up today
when I had him proposed to dummy as well
how emotional was that moment it was
just so beautiful I was so shocked yeah
yeah I wanted to surprise her I wonder
do you have that moment as well excite
it was such a big moment for me to
experience will you guys be the next
couple to get married together in
paradise
if it's great you were at Crystal and
Chris's wedding I mean you're open to it
like you said paradise is made for you
yeah the Queen is here so why not get
married in paradise maybe you guys
talked about it you have a timeline for
a wedding in oh my gosh no we just act
like bachelor world moves slow it's like
bachelor Rome is faster than the
engagement that's whenever people like
actually like take the time to be slow
about it yeah you're like wait a minute
okay let's be normal for a bit and date
and have fun and then the wedding will
come why do you guys work so well
together it's just like it's insane how
we're so different but it just works so
well you know I'm so blunt and bold and
all kinds of things and she's so gentle
and understanding and so sweet and soft
and it's just like a perfect balance you
two the first queer relationship in
franchise history big milestone moment
how would you like to see the show
tackle things in the future a lead one
day have you talked about that amongst
yourselves
you know I said before like I don't want
to be the one to carry the torch of how
bachelor nation or bachelor franchise
should like react to all of this kind of
stuff I think that it just will happen
naturally hopefully everything will just
be normalized you know won't be like oh
the queer couple bit oh the couple good
answer dummy
you
[Music]
[Applause]